[موسيقى]
شهر يناير هو الشهر الاول من شهور السنه
الميلاديه واحد سبعه شهور الذي يتكون من
31 يوما يسمى بالعراق وبلاد الشام بكانون
ثاني وهي لفظه عربيه ماخوذه من كنه اي
استقر في مكانه من شده البرد ويناير
ماخوذه من اللفظه اللاتينيه
والتي تعني البوابه فيناير بوابه الدخول
الى سنه ومداخيل الاشياء لها عند الشعوب
القديمه ومدخل السنه تسمى بجانوس عند
الرومان ولهذا يطلق البعض بجينوري وفيه
تحل الارواح الجديده على الارض وقاتل جسمي
مقتول بفعلته وقاتل الروح لا تدري به
البشر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ففي اول الشهر تكون الشمس في اقرب نقطه
لها من الارض بما يسمى بالحضيض الارض وفي
منتصفه موسم شباط وهو موسم الرياح الماكره
التي لا تستقر على جهه معينه واشباط مقطع
ارباط وفي نهايته الاستعداد لموسم بذره
الست وهي سته ايام صالحه لزراعه جميع
المحاصيل شتويه كانت ام صيفيه ثلاثه ايام
من اخر الشبط وثلاثه ايام من اول العقارب
ثلاثه ايام هي الدهر كلهم وما هن غير
الامس واليوم والغذي وما البدر الا واحد
غير انه يغيب وياتي بالضياء
المجددي
[موسيقى]